[Applause]
yeah I mean I've been called crazy sick
lunatic but only those who are sick like
me can understand I guess when you look
at me you think I'm the typical mother
of two suburban wife but when you get to
really know me you'll see what my
passion is people think I'm crazy they
don't understand what it is to have
heart palpitations the day you wake up
because there's playing a final they
don't know what it is to travel to
Europe and lose your voice 48 hours
before a game because you've been
chanting up and down the street
supporting your team and all that
sacrifice with 27 hours that it took me
to get this a 36 that then it was going
to take me to come back we're worth
every single
[Music]
so now this week Real Madrid is in town
they're playing Manchester United and
the International Champions Cup and this
is massive it's not everyday that
ramadhir it is in our hometown and we're
gonna make a count we've stocked them at
their hotel we stood out in the rain
yesterday getting autographs when they
were going in and out of their training
it is very very special to have them
here to see my son smile I mean to me it
is absolutely priceless
but really at the end of the day it's
all about the match just watching our
team play and celebrating with our
fellow man released us
it's quite the right I got to tell you
when the craziness happens all I can do
is just blow my eyes [ __ ] my shoulder
and say here we go again I decided it'd
be nice to bring her down in the field
and get to meet us go and the other
players but we're gonna get you on the
field today before I can introduce you
the boys
real for real Wow
never in my life could I ever dream that
I was
the same air that they're breathing
oh my god I can't believe us
just met ESCO he gave me two kisses like
in two respects
I am beside myself best day of my life
after their birth of course
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I cannot conceive my life without the
minute and I think if they weren't in it
I would just die
you